PROFESSOR: Our topic is
deviation from the mean,
meaning the probability that
a random variable returns
a value that differs
significantly from its mean.
Now, the Markov bound gave you a
course bound on the probability
that R was overly large
using very little information
about R. Not surprisingly,
if you know a little bit more
about the distribution of R,
simply that it's not negative,
you can state tighter bounds.
And this was noticed by a
mathematician named Chebyshev.
And he has a bound called
the Chebyshev bound.
Now, it's interesting that the
Markov bound, even though it's
very weak and seems
not very useful,
the Chebyshev bound,
which generally
gives you a significantly
stronger, invaluably stronger
bound on the probability that
a random variable differs much
from its mean is actually
a trivial corollary
of Markov theorem.
So that's just a very
simple ingenious way
to use Markov's bound to
derive Chebyshev bound.
And let's look at how.
So we're interested
in the probability
that a random variable R differs
from its mean by an amount x.
The distance between
R and its mean,
the absolute value
of R minus mu,
is greater than or equal to x.
We're trying to get a
grip on that probability
as a function of x.
Now, the point is that the event
that the distance between R
and its mean is greater than
or equal to x, another way
to say that is to square both
sides of this inequality.
It says that the event that
R minus mu squared is greater
or equal to x squared happens.
These two events are
just different ways
of saying the same set.
So therefore,
their probabilities
are equal trivially.
Now, what's nice about this
is, of course, that R minus mu
squared is a non-negative random
variable to which Markov's
theorem applies.
The square of a real
number is always
going to be non-negative.
So let's just apply
Markov's theorem
to this new random variable,
R minus mu squared.
And what does Markov's bound
tell us about this probability,
that the square
variable is greater
than or equal to an
amount x squared.
Well, just plug in Markov.
And it tells you
that this probability
that the square variable,
that it's as big as x squared,
is simply the expectation
of that squared variable
divided by x squared.
This is just applying Markov's
bound to this variable, R
minus u squared.
Now, this numerator is a
weird thing to stare at,
expectation of R minus
mu squared, and may not
seem very memorable.
But you should remember,
because it's so important
that it has name all it's own.
It's called the
variance of R. And this
is an extra bit of
information about the shape
of the distribution
of R that turns out
to allow you to state much more
powerful theorems in general
about the probability that
R deviates from its mean
by a given amount.
So we could just restate
the Chebyshev bound.
Just replacing that
expectation formula
in terms of its
name, variance of R,
this is what the
Chebyshev bound says.
The probability that the
distance between R and its mean
is greater than or equal to x
is the variance of R divided
by x squared,
where variance of R
is the expectation of
the square of R minus u.
Now, the very important
technical aspect
of the Chebyshev
bound is that we're
getting an inverse square
reduction in the probability.
Remember, with Markov,
the denominator
was behaving linearly.
And here, it behaves
quite quadratically.
So these bounds get
smaller, much more
rapidly as we ask about the
probability of differing
by a larger amount.
The variance of R, maybe
in a way that will help you
remember it is to remember
another name that it has.
It's called the
mean square error.
If you think of R
minus mu as the error
that R is making in
how much it differs
from what it ought to
be, and we square it,
and then we take the
average, so we're taking
the mean of the squared errors.
And here, we're back
to restating Markov
bound in terms of the variance.
The variance has one
difficulty with it.
And that leads us to want to
look at another object, which
is just the square
root of the variance,
called the standard deviation.
So you wonder why-- I mean,
if you understand variance,
what's the point of
taking the square root
and working with that?
And the answer is
simply that if you
think of R as a random
variable whose values have
some dimension, like seconds or
dollars, then the variance of R
is the expectation of a
square variable of R minus mu
squared, which means its
units are second squared
or dollar squared or whatever.
And the variance of R
itself is a squared value,
which is not reflecting the
magnitude of the distance
that you expect-- of
the kind of errors
that you expect R to make,
the distance that you expect
part R to be from its mean.
So we can get the
units of this quantity
back into matching
the units of R
and also get a number that's
closer to the kind of variance
that you'd expect to observe
by just taking the square root.
And it's called the
standard deviation of R.
If it helps you any, the
standard deviation is also
called the root
mean square error.
And you might have
heard that phrase.
It comes up all the
time in discussions
of experimental error.
So again, we're
taking the error--
means the distance between the
random variable and its mean.
We're squaring it.
We're taking the expectation
of that squared error.
And then we're taking
the square root of it.
It's the standard deviation.
So going back to understand what
the standard deviation means
intuitively in terms of a
familiar shaped distribution
function for a
random variable R,
suppose that R is a
random variable that
has this fairly
standard kind of bell
curved shape or Gaussian
shape, that it's got one hump.
It's unimodal.
And it kind of trails off
with some moderate rate,
as you get further and
further away from the mean.
Well, the mean of a distribution
that's shaped like this,
it's symmetric around that
high point, that's going
to be the mean by symmetry.
It's equally likely
to be-- well,
the values average out
to this middle value.
A standard deviation
for a curve like this
is going to be an interval
that you can interpret
as an interval around the mean.
And the probability that
you're within that interval
is fairly high for
standard distributions.
Now, we'll see that the
Chebyshev bound is not
going to tell us much about for
arbitrary unknown distribution.
But in general, for the
typical distributions,
you expect to find that the
standard deviation tells you
that that's where you're most
likely to be when you take
a random value of the variable.
So let's return to the Chebyshev
bound, as we've stated it.
And I'm just replacing here, I'm
restating the Chebyshev bound,
just replacing the variance
of R in the numerator
by the square of
its square root,
by sigma squared R. It's a
useful way to restate it.
Because by restating
it this way,
it motivates another
reformulation
of the Chebyshev bound
as we reformulated
the Markov bound
previously in terms
of a multiple of something.
I'm going to replace
x by a constant times
the standard deviation.
So I'm going to see the
probability that the error is
greater than or equal
to a constant times
the standard deviation.
And this term is
going to simplify.
Once x is a constant times
the standard deviation,
the standard deviations
are going to cancel out.
And I'm just going to wind
up with 1 over x squared.
So let's just do that.
And there's the
formula-- the probability
that the distance
of R from its mean
is greater than or
equal to a multiple c
of its standard deviation
is less than or equal to 1
over c squared.
So it's getting much more
rapidly smaller as c grows.
Let's look at what that
means for just some numbers,
to make the thing a
little bit more real.
What this assertion
is telling us
is that R is probably
not going to return
a value that's a
significant multiple
of its standard deviation.
For example, what
does this formula
tell us about the
probability that R
is going to be greater than or
equal to one standard deviation
away from its mean?
Well, it actually
tells us nothing.
That's the case in
which it's no good.
Because c is 1,
it's just telling us
that the probability is at
most 1, which we always know,
because probabilities
are at most 1.
But if I ask, what's the
probability that the error of R
is greater than or equal to
twice the standard deviation,
then this theorem is telling
me something nontrivial.
It's telling me that the
probability that it's twice
the deviation is 1
over 2 squared or 1/4.
An arbitrary random variable
with standard deviation sigma
is going to exceed
twice-- the error
is going to exceed twice the
standard deviation at most 1/4
of the time, three times at
most 1/9 of the time, four times
at most the 1/16 of the time.
So the qualitative
message to take away
is that, for any random
variable whatsoever, as long
as it has a standard
deviation sigma,
then you can say some definite
things about the probability
that the random
variable is going
to take a value that
differs by a large multiple
of the standard
deviation from its mean.
That probability is
going to be small
and get smaller
and rapidly smaller
as the multiple of the
standard deviation continues.